Mathematica is the only package that
will provide you with mathematical
functions tools to write research papers
or books to do simple calculations you
can very easily integrate with many
languages like Java or our my name is
Stephan KL I've been working as a
quantitative manager for almost 20 years
and for a trans from a little bit more
than 10 years I worked at several hedge
funds as the quantitative portfolio
manager so I developed my own trading
strategies and I was actually training
them I tried it several markets like
futures equities bonds only using
quantitative models so I started using
Mathematica in 2005 I had to build
futures investment process and I had to
implement the blacklist ominous
interrogation framework using several
factors I was using that model to mix
those effective portfolios into one
single portfolio and Mathematica
provided a good tool to do this because
of all the mathematical functions
already implemented it was able to come
up with a very short code that was doing
this in a very short period of time so I
had a choice between a software like
mathematica matlab ow
so I looked at software like L because
it was open-source the main issue I had
with our own is that you can find very
good query tool boxes but some are not
that good they are contributed by users
you don't know there are mathematical
skills so the quality of those tool box
is a very euro and it's not consistent
so that's why I started to look at
software like MATLAB or Mathematica
but Mathematica is the only software in
circles
there is nothing comparable to
to mathematica join like AI developed
training back testing platforms in
several languages in Java a C++ on
average it took me went to two month to
come up with something that was usable I
did the same thing recently Mathematica
- took me only two weeks another thing
that's nice is as Mathematica the
language itself is pure mathematics you
can write the mathematical formulae the
same way you see them in articles
basically by writing a back testing
engine in Mathematica you allow them
potential users to easily write new
strategies so if I was not able to use
Mathematica you would be faced with a
lot of issues because it's impacting so
many parts of the back testing workflow
that no longer access to Mathematica
would be very detrimental in terms of
productivity I would have to go back to
languages and spend much longer to
develop all those all those wages